ce midi aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de
pouvoir proposer une vidéo sur ce avril
wings line pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas saint-jo d'horreur
créé par mikami le créateur de resident
evil et c'est parti on est dans une des
bons des chapitres vite ce qui
correspond à peu près aux deux tiers du
jeu mais ne vous en faites pas y'a pas
de vilains spoil au niveau de l'histoire
et caetera et on va commencer par ouvrir
cette porte à on n'a pas regardé pendant
20 minutes
désolé je sais que j'en aie soit plus
d'un comment ils sont allés là où qui
sont ces gens le seul truc que je sais
c'est que là on entre dans la maison du
grand méchant du jeu et voilà ça c'est
de l'info au regard des que voici un
bocal y est on a de la monnaie c'est
probablement pour améliorer ses armes
etc et ses compétences je suppose où il
ya des gens payent top cool au nom il a
pas y'a pas fait un super héros on
enrichit la juste de la porte fermée et
maintenant quoi
bah je ne sais pas bonnes questions et
c'est carrément beau donc bien
évidemment on a accès à sa toutes ces
petites armes notamment à une petite
arbalète
là on est au pistolet et j'aime pas trop
cette maison je préfère vous le dire oh
oh oh [ __ ] mais c'était le bas des
marches au plus tard à l'armée mais y
avait je suis vraiment mais la pierre
des [ __ ]
or voilà encore un futur où les portes
se referment d'artois c'est génial ça il
ya du bruit on est bien d'accord
au hockey ce donc je m'en vais on va
partir de l'autre côté c'est pas mal
aussi l'autre côté on regarde et il ya
plein de choses
donc là je viens de ramasser un carreau
jolie d'arbalète qui apparemment glace
les ennemis c'est très bien voilà ça va
m'être très utile notamment pour glacer
les deux vilains qui sont là bas je sais
que ça mais j'ai jamais eu aussi peur
alors pourtant c'est pas du tout en n'en
savent attirer d'autres
je crois que je pouvais le désamorcer
mais j'ai pas réagi assez vite mon nexus
s est chaud aussi la couture ambitieux
table la rotule la rotule la rotule vite
vite non
la petite allumette kg mais en fait pas
du tout il ne se laisse pas faire il
faut vite que change d'armes
ça va partir sur un décès j'ai plus à
pons tais toi c'est quoi ça ces pêcheurs
voilà bombay ce début de jeu m eur ça
suffit
haha ça nous a fait plaisir c'est le
premier pas sur le jeu et je découvre en
même temps que vous un jeu pas vous le
dire parce que là c'était plutôt
catastrophique donc ça c'est très bien
c'est pour attirer les ennemis ailleurs
os qu'on va trouver vite thème rare qui
one shot toute la map assez un mécanisme
de coffre où on choisit le chiffre très
bien je prends j'accepte ça me plaît
bien à il attire mon regard sur quelque
chose sur ce tableau qui doit
probablement voulu à dire quelque chose
on va redescendre est ce que je pourrais
pas trouvé une forteresse de balle voilà
on va voir va là bas j'ai plus aucune
arme regarder je descends je descends il
voit pas en mer y en a un deuxième farc
ou rtl me sens elle me sens plus tard
l'ado doha regardez la elle convulsant
me sentant sa l'ex-site carrément moi ça
m'excite un peu mois touchera émission
3ème édition
oui c'était mieux mais ça c'est un
spasme bêtise oui des munitions on peut
brûler les corps comme ça allait le
style à ce qu'on les tuent ou est ce
concours comme des fillettes
moi j'aime bien l'option courait comme
une fillette si tu veux cette porte
humeur j'ai eu un mécanisme ça suffira
ouvrir cette porte j'en suis sûr j'ai
plus de barre d'endurance je vais crever
regardez le butin et se pose carrément
tranquillement tu veux un débat ce
moment stress des jeux pareil alors
est-ce qu il ya des monstres là dedans
non c'est bon par contre ne va fermer la
porte
ouvrons délicatement cette porte oh là
là là là mais ça met trop la pression
d'une ouverture de porte comme ça ya de
bons billets tombent vite la boum boum
boum sur lui non au regard des bonnes
bouteilles explose j'ai à faire ça non
les cras part micra paris craint pas les
guides je suis décédé ça devait finir
comme ça vous le savez je le sais il
fallait ça finisse comme ça c'était
obligé là on était tellement mal partis
l'une vipère envoyé sa lapine la
regarder up bin il va venir et ça va le
tuer non mais rien des îles à deux
centimètres de la bo puis le dessus
oui heures est décédé on va le brûlé au
cas où s'est jamais ouais créatures
démoniaques
regardez le il y en a un autre ou pas il
est seul il est seul mais pas innocent
non tu ne me vois pas ces normes
oui montre pas du doigt non pas du doigt
les gens comme ça saloperie de mal
éduqués oh oui des balles
merci pour les bars vraiment adorable je
serais encore en vie je te remercierai
non pas cette fois une machette
alors les arbres dans ce jeu tu l'ennemi
mais ne sont inaptes j'avais est une me
tuera qu'est ce qu'on a ici un cerveau
m'étais pas que le tibia mais en plus
sur pétassou bureau c'est bon c'est fini
alors qu'est ce que c'est donc que ce
cerveau what the fuck you c'est
carrément glauque
ok donc apparemment il faisait
d'expérience sur un cerveau et moelle
dans la finir tranquillement f 16 se
concentrer genre ok donc je dois le
mettre dans le f cette attention c'est
le tester c'est bon j'ai réussi
l'épreuve à monsieur monsieur maboul
je crois que c'est beau great viège et
réussi à opérer un cerveau alors je
crois qu'il se passe une seule la allait
bien on est on est un tweet des hommes
de science tu penses que je suis une
sorte de monstre j'essaie de traduire
mais mon avis de scientifiques qui se
parlent dont celui droite je crois qui
faisait scientifique un peu bizarre un
peu comme celle ci à l'instant avec un
cerveau humain est bien le mouzon a
trouvé une autre porte
je veux me balader avec une bouteille à
la main je n'aime pas trop ça
est ce qu'on peut trouver des trucs plus
je savais que ces nouvelles idées je
savais je savais j'aurais dû prendre
plus à pompe et bien sûr ma chère mois
comme il faut bon pas cette fois best
friend
[ __ ] il en a fait mal pour le tuer
look ouf j'ai cru que j'allais encore
boury elle ça suffit monsieur ça suffit
avec vos boutures dans le ventre on peut
continuer désormais c'est ça la bonne
nouvelle nous revoici donc assez à
manger en voilà des balles à yes et des
aînés qui résistent plus aux balles que
d'autres en fait selon leur morphologie
battant lui était fin comme une baguette
quoi pourquoi il ya résisté je ne sais
pas non regardez je n'ai découvert un
petit é on peut se cacher là dessous des
fois il apparaît pour nous faire peur à
parce qu'il est très villa on peut se
cacher sous une table comme un foetus
c'est bon il s'en est allé je peux
sortir deuxième salle fait il nous reste
sept mois atteint j'ai enclenché un
mécanisme tout à l'heure en opérant le
cerveau et par avance a servi à ouvrir
la porte donc faut que j'aille dans la
salle orford pour une [ __ ] c'est rien
ok le cas des torontois un peu un petit
et pitié j'ai plus de vie soyez l'union
gentillet ni ohlala
olala yens celle là à des bals en fait
t'es content que tu trouves des
munitions n'étaient pas trop content de
plus parce que tu sais que ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir un petit peu le
brouhaha 1 comme on dit au quai première
porte
donc je pense qu'il faut lui mettre une
bonne balle dans le derrière quoi boom
au nom bout au nom boom non non non non
vous bouffe a très bien tu as tout ça
pour une salle vide
hier il a en fait ça se redonner de la
vie je crois bien regarder hop une
petite pique use est effectivement ma
vie remonter un [ __ ] mais pas fou
alors attention à j'aime pas trop de
bruit on va dans cette salle ou pas le
magazine ok c'est bon voyez une salle
qui va coûter cabale ça va qu'est ce que
c'est que ça des balles une grenade mais
là c'est que ça va être la guerre il
manque le deuxième où je les mettais pas
que j'étais à l'étagé à droite
ok montre toi jeune démon sur du placard
mais pas qu'il va être là haut je crois
que vraiment quand je passe comme ça ils
n'explosent pas très intelligent ces
pièges à aaa
calme toi donc ça c'est fait nous reste
la salle en eau a je ne préférais ne
jamais devoir y aller masculine
c'est le deuxième et kahnisme il va se
passer un truc il est où il est où me
dis pas qu'il apparaît dans cette salle
si la prudence est sincère et cardiaques
cette technique marche toujours y
compris cette fois au [ __ ] il met la
pression lui qu il apparaît et là c'est
le méchant tu as l'air je crois que
c'était le haut du tableau qu'on avait
je ne sais pas bon en tout cas on a deux
un mécanisme et ça c'est génial mois
pour le mettre en place de manière
immédiate
je me méfie toujours le premier m'a
traumatisé je ne veux plus avoir à faire
ce genre de choses alors un [ __ ] font
un code 20 minutes de recherches
intensives plus tard c'est ça comme
ciment foulée toujours sur scène alors
fait c'était 11 ans au parce que premier
tableau qu'on a vu donc la partie du
haut du tableau et y avait onze
personnages dessus et de haut en bas
parce que deuxième tableau qu'on a vu
l'arrivée de me succéder guillotiné
bonne femme qui pleurait y avait deux
personnages dessus voilà en lala qui
sait que ce sont trois bons gars ouvrons
la porte
ça va être une autre opération 3 encore
voilà c'est ça c'est notre opération
alors c'est parti
oh la la c'est un pas propre tout ça pas
encore trouvé l'autre y'a pas un petit
j'ai un petit schéma encore à la voilà
sujet numéro 14 test 88 c'est ok donc
cette fois je crois que tom est réduite
dans la partie sekkat aux halles et là
on y va c'est pas ça c'est ça y est
semée chirurgien professionnel où est
mon diplôme s'il vous plaît donc la rfm
liquide qui va aller dans la porte
il ya une sauvegarde automatique j'ai vu
donc on va sortir de manière immédiate
ou revolver on sait jamais ce qui peut
se passer
l'hôpital n'a pas reçu les donations
habituel des familles et pourquoi est ce
qu elle fait quelque chose de mal et que
ces deux nations la famille victoria
notes jour était à contribuer à un
généreux ou sur tes parents ils sont
partis comment osez vous rendre dans ma
maison et à me traiter bonne question
1 comment il a osé c'est vrai ça non
c'est bon voilà au jedi the way back
il faut que je m'étais dit m elles
mettent non leurs allumettes vite le
grand le gros le gros faux j'allume faut
que j'allume au pl oui j'ai allumé c'est
bon un beau à l'image en plus un très
très beau à l'image lui par exemple il
lui fallait sur 22 balles dans la rue
pour qu'elle se casse cou badawi manque
un tuyau regarder il manque un truc là
ok alors normalement il ya des ennemis
qui sont à droite là du coup faisait pas
déclencher quand j'avais fait le truc
est ce que je peux passer sans trop les
déranger vous pensez il ya plein de
trucs non je préfère les tuer ya plein
de trucs
non non non non ta gueule tlf non non
recherche vite c'est l'heure du truc de
secours au kenya où j'eus idées de merde
salut ok pas pitié c'était trop malin ok
t'as j'aurais mieux fait de les éviter
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils vont lâcher au
moins des outils très bien des
allumettes
ttout ya pas de boy arias mais comment
vais je faire oui oui oh là là trois
balles ok encore des choses s'il vous
plaît je veux toujours plus de balle
toujours plus de choses
qu'est ce que c'est que ça rien medikits
très bien je crois me soigner de manière
non limitée medikits 12 allée médiatique
toi voilà un petit coup de seringue et
hop tout comme ça c'est pas prévu par
contre au nom d'un homme mais non
monsieur mais non mais ne me faites pas
un infarctus non il ya une chaise entre
nous oh non non non monsieur
voilà je me fais sauter avec au nom il
ya eu seize d'entre nous d'accord on le
trouve qu'on vient de ramasser dans la
caisse à outils il en faut 5 pour faire
un carreau d'arbalète c'est quoi cette
arnaque
pourquoi il en faut pas qu'à 20 ans je
joue comme un bourrin quoi j'avoue que
je suis vraiment pas doué sur les jeux
comme ça un carreau d'arbalète qui
foudroie ça me plaît bien ça non non non
non wish it
d'accord d'accord d'accord d'accord j'ai
raté
la corde alors au nom non au nom aussi
je me fais je sais même pas où j'ai tiré
le dernier probablement la roue pour
d'émotion voilà qui est bien mieux
bon pour accéder à cette porte au
dernier mais cannes et ce pour ouvrir la
porte centrale ross un petit passage
secret ça un temps acheminé hier à ça
fait plaisir
voilà c'est vraiment j'ai beaucoup
d'émotion actuellement dernière
opération reçu cerveau c'est parfait le
a deux filles a donc logiquement
sevrette la chirurgie un professionnel
c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire je sens
que des petits copains se sont joints à
la fête
regardez avatar il va tuer son père en
fait lui c'est le méchant du jeu cole
était petit et en fait là on voit des
souvenirs à lui on comprend pourquoi il
est devenu méchant trop trad oncle
apparemment et bien tué son père c'est
le début de sa carrière de jeunes
psychopathe
est ce que cette porte est enfin ouverte
et plein de bridge on me l'a alors
entrons donc dans cette fameuse grande
porte qui se referme direct comme toutes
les portes mais un col haut c'est le
méchant c'est le méchant c'est le
méchant
à oslo
pas de traitement pour ce que je suis en
train de te faire watts que c'était que
ça qu'est ce qu'elle faisait là
elle faisait des expériences sur une
tête de cochon bon je suppose que c'est
par là un c'est un peu seul au bonjour
monsieur
au revoir monsieur qui était pas très
social malheureusement je suis triste
sans lui bonjour mais ça va a une jolie
porte derrière laquelle se cache
ce petit garçon
ou la toux s'excite
à des flashs de souvenirs
très bien the avait loué m et voilà on a
terminé la démo m'a écouté j'espère que
ce sera plus en tout cas moi j'ai bien
kiffé je pensais pas avoir aussi peur au
début du jeu et c'est vrai que
l'ambiance est bien posant qu'elle puise
souvent il ya des ennemis qui
apparaissent à des endroits où tu t'y
attends pas trop faim moi en tout cas je
m'attends pas peut-être parce que je
suis demeuré n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
si vous voulez un exploit sur the bill
within à sa sortie en octobre je pense
qu'il sera au moins sous titres en
français donc y aura pas trop de
problèmes de compréhension un bon à
l'aller on avait déjà pas pourtant
d'ici là c'est promis je me réfère à des
mots pour m'entraîner parce que c'est
vrai que là j'ai été vraiment nul j'ai
un peu honte joola vous pour s'affronter
dans une nouvelle vidéo chat ou le monde
pis
[Musique]
oui